bu Gamze Yüksel Ben Muğla Sıtkı Koçman
Üniversitesi Fen Fakültesi Matematik
Bölümü öğretim üyesi ve aynı zamanda fen
bilimleri Yapay Zeka anabilim dalı
başkanlığını yürütmekteyim Bu dönem yeni
açıldı lisansüstü programı ve ilk defa
Türkiye'de lisansüstü anlamdır programı
bulaşık Koçman Üniversitesi açmış oldu
dolayısıyla ben size bugün Aslında bu
Ortaklar Fen Lisesinin düzenlediği
yenilikçi ve ilerici etkinliğiniz için
Öncelikle tebrik ediyorum hepinize böyle
birşey sebep olduğumuz için ben bu
yenilikçi ve ileri gençlere genel bir
bilgi vermek istiyorum ve yapay zekanın
içerisinde matematik nerede bunu olan
ilişkisini kurmak istiyorum aslında
sıklıkla duyuyorsunuz Dur Belki
Bugünlerde Yapay Zeka terimini ama
kabarcığı tanımlayacak olursa aslında
insana özgü olan davranışları mantık
yürütme hareket etmeye konuşma ses
ve bunun gibi birçok yeteneği makinalara
yazılımsal ve donanımsal sistemler
olarak iletilmesi yani yazılımsal ve
donanımsal sistemlerin bütünü Aslında
Yapay Zeka dediğimiz şey ve bunu insana
özgü davranışları bakiye kazandırmak
için kullanılan bir bir ara bilim
açıkçası Şu an için gündemdeki durumu bu
tabi aslında şu son zamanlarda çok
duymaya başlamış olsak da biz
tarihçesine bakacak olursak yapay
zekanın doğuşu 1950 yıllarına kadar
gidiyor bu da elin Turing İngiliz
matematikçi elim Turing ilk defa
makineler düşünebilir mi Pardon
makineler düşünebilir mi adlı yayınıyla
birlikte bu konunun öncüleri haline
getirmiş oluyor Onun dışında da aynı
zamanda İkinci Dünya Savaşı'nda savaşın
erken
bir sebep olan en iyi bak şifresini
Almanların unutma şifreleyici
makinesinin sırlarını çözerek
şifrelerini çözerek bilgisayarın ilk
kurucuları Ali ne de ilk kurucusu olarak
da yer almış oluyor Bundan başka Aslında
yine bu zamanlarda birtakım İşte bu
konuyla ilgili hikayeler ve işte
Seminerler konferanslar düzenlemeye
başlıyor Ancak altın çağını 1956 74
arasında yaşamaya başlıyor Yapay Zeka
daha çok bu altınçağda yapılan şeyler de
aslında perceptron kavramının ortaya
atılması Biraz sonra size Bunun tam
olarak ne olduğunu açıklayacağım aynı
zamanda yine bu altınçağda ilk defa
Yapay Zeka ismimizi tarafından bir
çalıştayda kullanılmaya başlanıyor sonra
gelişmiş devletler bu yapay zekayı olan
yatırımlarından bekledikleri e çıktıları
alamayınca yapay zekayı olan yatırımları
kesiyorlar ve yapay zeka 74/80 arasında
bir kuş devrimine giriyor kış dönemine
giriyor bu dönemde fazla bir
Bu kaydedilemiyor ancak 80'lerden sonra
tekrar bir hazırlık tekrar bir hızlanma
çabası içerisinde görüyoruz yapay çiçek
Yapay Zeka çalışmalarını mesela aybiyem
indik Blue adlı yazılımını satranç
şampiyonu kasparov'un 1997 yılında
yeniyor biliyorsunuz ki satranç
stratejik boyun ve ilk hamle için ilk
oyuncunun 20 olasılığı iki oyuncunun da
karşı anne için yeni olasılığı var
Böylelikle toplamda ilk almaya çizgili
ilk karşılıklı ama için 400 olasın var
ve bu olasılıklar zinciri büyüyerek
gidiyor ve artık makina bu algoritmik
düzende Makina insanlığın gösterebilecek
performansları odası seçimlerini
öngörerek insanı yenebilecek seviye
gelebiliyor insanüstü bir seviyeye
ulaşabiliyor sonrasında yine derin sinir
ağları dediğimiz sinir alır da 52006
yılında çalışılmaya başlanıyor Apple'ın
asistanı Siri Asistan 2011 yılında
tasarlanıyor Sonrasında da cep you
bu dediğimiz 2012'den günümüze kadar
devam eden bir çağ var burada Aslında
önemli olan şu daha önceki
bilgisayarlardaki işlemciler sprey u
işlemci iken bu oyunda endüstrisinin
gelişimi ile birlikte de grafik
tasarımına daha çok ağırlık verildiği
için Çiftliği yolu işlemciler artık
bilgisayarlarda çoğunlukla kullanılmaya
başlıyor Bunlar çok daha seviyor
işlemcilere göre hızlı çalışabiliyorlar
ve de aynı zamanda cep telefonlarında
hayatımıza girmesiyle birlikte İran'da
veri ortalıkta çok fazla bulunmaya
başlıyor bize ait veriler birçok
görseller resimler sesler verin bir anda
çılgınca büyüdüğü bir zaman aynı zamanda
cips yiyor işlemciyle bilgisayarlarla
birleşince Aslında yapay zekadaki son
gelişmelerdeki patlamaların sebebi bu
oluyor ve bununla birlikte Aslında yine
burdan Apple burada Google'ın dip Mayıs
adlı iPhone logosu
Evet bu da googlego oyununu yine uzak
doğuya dayanan bir bu oyunun şampiyonu
yine yenerek insanüstü bir zekaya
ulaşabiliyor bu da insan üstü zeka
Dediğiniz zaman sadece belirli Komutları
yerine getirebiliyor dikkat edin yani
belirli bir oyunda insan üstü zeka
seviyesine ulaşıyor Ama bu insanüstü
zekaya ulaşan yazılım başka bir işte
Tabii ki eksik kalabiliyor Bundan başka
yapay zekanın temelinde neler var eğer
onlara bakacak olursak Tabi ki
Bilgisayarda bir şeyler öğretmenini söz
konusu olduğu için makinaları bir şeyler
öğretmenidir Kafanız olduğu için
bilgisayar bilimi bunun temelinde ve
aynı zamanda bilgisayara bir şeyler
öğretirken kullanacağımız araçta
matematik olduğu için matematikte bu
işin temelinde Bunun dışındaki diğer
kavramlar insana ait davranışları
makinalara öğretmenim öğretmen
felsefesinde dayandığı için aslında
insana ait ne varsa felsefe Psikoloji
Sosyoloji dilbilimi kavram bilimi
bir şey kimya Yani insanın davranışını
modelleri ne varsa aslında yapay zekanın
onu su içerisinde de giriyor yapay zeka
ile birlikte belki sıklıkla makine
öğrenimi derin öğrenme gibi kavramları
da duymuş olabilirsiniz Aslında bunların
temeli engelli Yapay Zeka yani algılayan
son çıkaran aksiyon alan adapte olan
programların geneline Yapay Zeka diyor
Eğer ki ver miktarındaki artışa göre bir
de matematiksel algoritmalarda işin
içine girerse yani yapay zekanın 16
sınıfına makine öğrenimi adı veriliyor
bu daha fazla bebek ve matematiksel
algoritmaların yönlendirdiği kısma
makine öğrenimi geliyor Eğer veri sayısı
çok büyükse büyük boyutlarda verici
olabilir Bunun anlamı derin ağlarda bu
çok katmanlı alan ağlarda Eğer
eğitilerek bir öğrenmek için
sağlanıyorsa Buna da derin öğrenme
deniyor Bu da öğrenme kelimelerini
yalnız yani eğitim bilimlerinde ki
öğrenme ile karıştırmayalım burada
makinaları
Evet öğretme söz konusu olduğu için
temeli matematiğe dayanıyor yapay
zekanın aslında şu an günümüzde oldukça
fazla kullanılan alanlar var Zaten
hepimiz cep telefonu kullanıyoruz cep
telefonlarında fotoğraf çektiğinizde Bu
yüz tanıma dediğimiz Algoritma bir Yapay
Zeka uygulaması Onun dışında netflix'te
bize önerilen filmler spotify'da bize
önerilen müzikler Bunlar herbiri birer
Yapay Zeka uygulaması Bundan başka
tarımda sağlıkta robotikte eğitimde
sosyal medyada birçok alanda Aslında
uygulamaları var Ve daha da artmaya
devam edecek Ben sizin ilginiz şekilde
çalışıyor yapacak ya da çalışıyorum
matematik Bunun Neresinde diyecek olursa
sanki matematik Bize biraz formüller
bizim yemiş gibi geliyor her tarafta da
formüller ve bu formüllerin ne işe
yarayacağını Biz bilemiyor muşuz gibi
geliyor Yani hep öğrenciler sorarlar
bize de soruyorlar bu matematik benim ne
işime yarayacak diye Aslında şöyle bir
şey var ki Rus matematikçi loş Keskin
bu gibi matematiğin hiçbir dalı yoktur
ki ne kadar soyut olursa olsun bir gün
gerçek dünyada uygulama alanı bulması
yani şu Biz matematikçiler soyut
matematik ve yapıyorum matematik olsun
uygulamalı matematik olsun Aslında
matematiği matematikçi yapanlar yapan
insanların ve bunun yeri geliyor bazen
mühendis Yeri geliyor bazen sağlıkçı bir
yeri geliyor bir günde fen bilimleri
çalışanı Oo yapılan matematiği alıp
kullana bir teknoloji üretiyor
Dolayısıyla aslında ama matematik
matematik için yapılan ve her daim
yapılan çıktısında da aslında Çok da
matematikçi ilgilendirmeyen bir durum
yani o matematik matematik için yapıyor
şu an üzerinde yaşamadığımız Uzaylılar
arasındaki uzaklık kavramlarını
topolojik kavramları oluşturmaya
çalışıyor Sonra onu gelip bir gün bir
uygulamadır hiçbir bilim adamı alıp
kullanarak yeni ürün Yeni teknoloji
geliştirebiliyor burada şundan bahsetmek
istiyorum aslında bu matematik ne işe
yarıyor kavramı sadece sizlerin problemi
değil biliyorsunuz Abbas Güçlü ile bir
eğitim yaz
bu gazetesinde o da aynı şekilde bu soru
bu soruyu sormuş bu matematiği Niye ben
öğrenmek zorundayım benim sınıf geçmek
demesine işime yaradı sorusu Onun da
gündemine geldi Birkaç yıl öncesinde
bunu Aslında en güzel cevabı bu anlamda
matematikçi Ali Nesin vermiş oldu orada
bu cevabı Sizinki de da hatırlatmak
istiyorum matematik somut Tekbir çıktısı
olmayan bir şey yani onu anlamadım bir
şeye yaramaz ama matematik her şeyi
içinde var yaşadığımız evrenin Onun
dışında üzerinde bulunduğumuz dünyanın
yani içerisinde düzen olan her şeyi
tarif etmeye yarayan şey matematik
Dolayısıyla matematik bir şeye yaramaz
her şeye yarar Yani biz Ben bunun
matematiği Bu anlamda anlamaktan
bilmekten Başka çaremiz yoksa bir burada
biraz bizim matematikçilerin matematik
öğretmenlerimiz İzlerinde üstüne
sorumluluklar düşüyor anlattığımız
forumlarda şey sayılar kavramından
fonksiyonlar kavramından limitte
süreklilik tekrardan bahsederken bu da
öğren
bu Belki bu konu ne işe yarıyor günlük
hayattaki uygulamaları ne çıktıları ne
bu konuda biraz bilgi verebilirse kör
öğrencilerin kalbine giden yolu bu
anlamda e keşfetmiş oluruz ve matematiğe
olan ilgilerini arttırabiliriz Tabi bu
anlamda öğretmenlerimizin biraz
araştırma yapması kendilerini
geliştirmeleri gerekiyor şimdi yapay
zeka ile matematik arasındaki ilişki ne
diye soracak olursak Az önce söylemiştik
makinaları Biz aslında insan gibi
davranabilen düşünün davranabilen görsel
algılayabilen konuşabilen sistemler
bölüm bütün demiştik Yapay Zeka içinde
Tamam lı algoritmaları sayısal
çektikleri dayanırım Dolayısıyla
matematik yapay zekanın Aslında her
kısmında var Yapay zekalı birçok alanı
var ama her kısmında matematiği görmek
mümkün mesela görüntü tanıma da biz bu
ekranda gördüğünüz 5e benzeyen
görüntünün 5 olarak tanıtmak istiyorum
Ben bilgisayara ve bundan sonra mesela
böyle milyonlarca beşg
Oh be o milyonlarca gösterdim 5 dışında
milyon başka hiç tanımadığı 15 görseli
gördüğünü Evet bu beşe benziyor dik beş
tanesini isteyeceğim makinada 5 buna beş
derken makineye öğretirken bakın
buradaki gördüğümüz matris olarak onu
öğretmeniz gerekiyor buradaki hiç sel
Pixel koyuluk açıklara göre en açığı
sıfır en koyusu 16 olarak belirtilmiş
olan burada 5 rakamını Biz Max olarak
bilgisayara tanıta Biliyoruz tabii
burada sayıları kullanırken skalerler
kullanabiliyoruz bazen beklerler
kullanabiliyoruz hapisler
kullanabiliyoruz ve hatta sensör
dediğimiz daha yüksek boyutlu sayı
yapılarını kullanıyoruz yani girdileri
biz bu gaz sayısal veriler olarak
bilgisayarı yapıyor mesela 8'de görmesi
için bilgisayarın tanıması için buradaki
yeni Pixel Pixel sıfırdan 256 ya kadar
belirtilmiş sayılarla 8'i tanımasını
sağlıyor yani 8 sayısının
ne olacak bilgisayar Sadece böyle
tanımaktadır kalmayacak Bu bahçesi
işleyerek Yapay Zeka üzerindeki
algoritmalarda çalıştırması gerekiyor
sekizli sadece tanıtmak için sayı
kullanmıyorum öp programı işletmek için
de yine matematiksel araçlar kullanmak
gerekiyor Dolayısıyla matematik burada
her yerde diyebiliriz Bir de bu başta
bahsetmiştim sektörün kavramı var Yapay
sinir ağları kavramı Aslında bu yapay
sinir ağları dediğimiz şey yani makineye
bir şey öğretmeyi burada düşünce olarak
insanların öğrenmesi taklit edilerek
yapılmış ve nasıl ki biz sinir
uçlarınıza gelen Şu dersliklere Gelen
uyaranları hücre boyunca ileti pakson
üzerinden ileti tekrar sinir ucunu
oradan başka bir sürü buradan Bey ne
kadar iletip Bu da mesela diyelim ki
Elimizi sobaya dediğinde Elimizi canım
sıcak değil çektiğimizde orada bir
sobanın sıcak olabileceğini öğrendiğiniz
gibi burada makineye bir şey öğretirken
bu buradaki yap
500x bir eksiklik suç dediğimiz
verilerimiz yani ortamda soba varsa
ortamın sıcaklığı fazlaysa soba
yaklaştıkça bu sıcaklık artıyorsa gibi
veriler var mesela elimizde ve bunları
Bunlar onlardan drone dediğimiz işlem
bilgi işlem kutucuklarını küçük
hücrelerde işleyerek sonucunda Diyoruz
ki evet bu soba sıcak ve işte elin
yanabilir çiftçisine ediyorsun Bu da her
biri ağırlıklarına göre bu yediler
ağırlıklarına göre Bunlar onlarda işlemi
sonucunda bu soba sıcak çıktı sinir
ediyorlar yani insandaki öğrenme şekli
makineye aktarılmıştır bunun için böyle
çok katmanlı çok verili ağlar
çalıştırıyor derin öğrenme dediğimiz şey
kabaca bu mesela burada bir çiçek
görüntüsünü çiçeği tanıması için
bilgisayarın yapılan şey şu an buradaki
Pixel Pixel yine çiçeğin üzerinde içi
şeyi parçalıyor ve oradaki renklerine
göre önce basit şekilleri daha sonra
daha kompleks fikirleri sonrasında 5'te
çiçeğini belirt
çok sıcak bir takım köşe kenar
bulgularını birleştirerek işte diyor ki
198 olasılıkla bu bir çiçek Bunu git
mesela milyonlarca çiçek resmini Sistem
eğitiyorsunuz sonra başka eğitim demiş
başka bir beri kullanıyorsun başka bir
çiçek gösteriyorsunuz o da ona 498
odasında çiçek yani makina bu şekliyle
çiçeği tanıyor ve öğrenebiliyor ve bu
arada yapılan işlemler Ee hepsi
matematiksel bir takım fonksiyonlar
yardımıyla yapıyor Mesela bu ileri
yayılmadı Lojistik regresyon dedim ileri
yayılma formülü dikkat ederseniz
buradaki bekleriz ağırlık vektörlerinin
logaritma fonksiyonu var toplam sembolü
Buzlar bu ücretlerde bu fonksiyonlar
çalışarak bir sonraki adıma geçebiliyor
Onun dışında Mesela diyelim ki burada
bir yeni video göstermek istiyorum Size
bu noktaları lineer regresyon problemi
bunda noktaların tahmin eden bir Pardon
İslami şimdi indireyim noktaları
şu an doğruyu bulmak istiyoruz yani
burada belli verilerimiz var ve bu
noktaları en iyi tahmin yapacak en iyi
fit yapacak doğruyu bulmak istiyoruz
aslında burada bir para hata fonksiyonu
devreye giriyor bu hata fonksiyonu muz
Bizim aynı zamanda bir yüzey belirtmiş
ve bu hata fonksiyonun minimumu aynı
zamanda bu doğrunun bu noktaları
fethettiği yer Sen de tam üstüne
oturduğu yer bir fonksiyonu minimum lan
bahsediyorsak Aslında bakın minimum
noktasına doğru geldi bu nokta şuradan
başlayarak Buraya doğru geldi
fonksiyonlu Mini bulmak demek
biliyorsunuz ki süre bilgisi
gerektiriyor Dolayısıyla bu minimum
olduğu zaman bu doğru da bu noktaların
üzerine fit ediyor Yani tam olarak
oturuyor artık ben o noktaları bu doğru
yardımıyla salınmaya biliyorum Burada
dediğimiz gibi bi hata fonksiyonun
türevleri işin içerisine giriyor hata
fonksiyonlu şey olmak üzere onun ağırlık
Back türlerine göre türevlerini almak
gerekir
ve dolayısıyla matematik dediğimiz gibi
bunun daha örnekleri sıralamak mümkün
her yerinde her anlamda matematik
kullanıyoruz Bir de size kabaca lisede
olan ve üniversite hazırlık aşamasında
olan gençlerimiz için bir takım
tavsiyelerde bulunmak istiyorum bu
geleceğin meslekleri kitabı var Şebnem
Özdemir hocamızın çıkardı Deniz Kılıç
hocamızla birlikte Biraz sonra ileride
onu kaynaklar kısmında Göstereceğim size
burada yenileceğim mesleklerinde
insanların kazanması gereken yani iyi
bir meslek sahibi olduk mesleğini
sürdürebilmesi için kazanması gereken
yetenekler araştırıldığında 2015 yılında
karmaşık problem çözme bir sırada iken
2020'de kalmış problem çözme yine bir
sırada pratik düşünme ikinci sırada
yaratıcılık üçüncü sırada bunlar aynı
zamanda matematiğin dolaylı çıktıları da
yani sadece fonksiyon limit süreklilik
süre kullanmak değil yapay zekalı
yapacağımız işlem Onun dışında
matematikle uğraşarak matematik
düşüncemiz Bak bu karmaşık problem çözme
en kritik düşünme yeteneğimizi gelişecek
ve biz her dönemde de mesleği iyi en iyi
anlamda icra edebilen kişiler olacağız
Bu anlamda matematik Her meslek grubu
için bizim için çok önemli olduğunu
düşünüyorum Bu Geleceğim mesleklerinde
biraz da ilmek istersek bakın ileride
Eskiden meslekler 30 40 yıllık
periyotlarla değişmiş bu Yapay Zeka
destekli sistemlerle birlikte Özellikle
bu komut 19 sonrasında 19'da bakın insan
üretim sektöründen elini ayağını çektiği
zaman her şey durdu artık üretim
sektöründe insan olmadan makinaların yer
aldığı bir dönem bizi bekliyor bekliyor
Böyle olunca da birçok meslek tarihe
karışacak ve yeni meslekler ortaya
çıkacağım veri bilimci sizleri ama eski
kullanıcı deneyimi insan-makine
etkileşimi tasarımcıları yapay zeka ve
robotik mühendisi gibi birçok evet eski
meslekler kaybolacak Belki şoförü
kaybolacak Çünkü artık oto araçları
bineceğiz Ama onun yerine yeni
bir şeyler gelecek ve demiyor ki
meslekleri periyotları beş yılda bir
değişecek Siz üniversite sınavında
kazandığınız bir yere girdim bir meslek
sahibi olmak istiyorsunuz o bölüme
girdiğinizde Eğer İyi düşünmezsiniz iyi
değerlendirmesi çıktığımızda Belki o
meslek olmayacak dolayısıyla böyle her
daim olabilecek teknoloji tabanlı
meslekleri yönelimini sağlarsanız
şimdiden Bu kaybı yaşamış olursunuz eğer
onun dışında Son olarak size Az önce
bahsettiğim gibi birkaç film ve kitap
önerisinde bulunmak istiyorum bu konuyu
merak salonları öğrenmek isteyenler daha
detaylı öğrenmek isteyenler için cemsa
hocanın Boğaziçi Üniversitesi bilgisayar
mühendisliği hocası 50 soruda Yapay Zeka
Az önce çevremizde bilmediğiniz kıvılcım
bahsettiğim geleceğin meslekleri
muhakkak okuyun üniversite arifesinde
olan gençler tercih yapacaklar için çok
önemli yeni yapay zekaya daire kitapları
okumanızı filmleri izlemenizi tavsiye
ederim Ufak bir araştırmayla Google'da
bu filmlere ulaşabilirsiniz Onun dışında
netflix Black Mirror diye biri
ve her bölümü ayrı bir Yapay Zeka
teknolojisi anlatıyor ve bu bir
teknoloji birkaç gün içinde gerçek
hayatımıza giriyor yere diyor
Dolayısıyla Yani bu konuda Kendimizi
geliştirmek için etrafta artık bilgiye
ulaşım mümkün kendimize içebilirsiniz Bu
anlamda bölümler yazıp bu alanı
okuyabilirsiniz Acet tepede top etüde
üçüde Yapay Zeka mühendisleri açıldı
açıldı başka birçok üniversitede bizim
içimizde olduğumuz Muğla Üniversitesi bu
alanda çalışmalarını yapıyor benim bu
konuda matematik ve yapay zeka anlamda
Söyleyeceklerim bu kadar teşekkür
ediyorum Biraz hızlıca konuştum süreyi
aşmamak için bu